Hey, David, if there were a mandatory gun
buyback in the United.
Could it really work?
Would people really participate?
Very complicated question.
So let's first just make sure we're on the
same page.
If you mean, could the United States say all
guns must be turned in.
And we will buy them off of you.
You don't get that if you don't repeal the
Second Amendment.
I spent some time reading about this.
I don't see any way that there could be a
nationwide overarching umbrella, mandatory
gun buyback without changing the fact that
people do have a right to own firearms, as
confirmed by the Supreme Court.
Now, if you want to look at something different,
like, for example, a certain type of firearm
has been banned.
And if you have one, you have to turn it in.
You will have a higher success rate with that,
both legally and in terms of getting getting
societal participation.
But I don't see how in a country with a Second
Amendment, you can do a mandatory gun buyback.
So my first question would be, how do you
address the Second Amendment?
You have to dismantle that right, which the
Supreme Court precedent supports in order
to do it.
If you could do it.
OK.
Cost really is an issue.
I mean, we we've 300 million firearms.
Is it 300 or 350 million firearms floating
around in the United States?
This is why when we talk about.
Well, demilitarize the police.
Yes.
Police with no guns in the U.S., it's tougher
because so many people have guns in countries
where fewer citizens have guns.
Sure.
I think that's an obstacle here.
So.
So then what is the cost?
Because of the number of guns that are floating
around.
Could be hundreds of billions of dollars could
could be high, hundreds of billions of dollars,
depending on how it would be structured.
I know that the government can just you know,
not even it's not even print.
It's digitally create money.
But I see that as very tough politically to
imagine.
And then if you can get through the legal
and the financial.
The truth is that some other much less aggressive
acts haven't been super successful.
I looked at the New York Safe Act and it saw
of it was based on assault weapons of the
million that are registered in the state,
I believe only 45000 assault weapons were
turned in.
That's very, very low compliance.
Now, there are places that have been able
to do this.
The UK, New Zealand, Australia, they have
smaller populations, fewer guns floating around,
national gun registries.
So by and large, the country knows where a
lot of those guns are and they don't have
anything in their constitution that is deemed
gun ownership a right.
It's these are laws and the laws can be changed.
They had a lot of success there.
The problem I have believing this would be
feasible as an immediate next step in the
United States, as some have suggested, is
that the genie is out of the bottle in terms
of the Second Amendment, in terms of the number
of guns that are out in circulation.
So I think to really, if this is your priority
and I believe that there is lower hanging
fruit that we should be looking at first to
create a better infrastructure, where then
we could maybe start getting some guns off
of the street.
But if you want to go first to a gun buyback,
you first have to deal with the Second Amendment.
You secondly, have to deal with the financial
piece.
And third, how do you enforce it?
The law enforcement would not be able to enforce
it.
And even a few years, given the number of
guns that are out there, what exactly would
be the plan?
I'm not being defeatist.
I'm just being a realist.
And I would love for you to tell me where
where I'm wrong on this.